on y est érigée au prix d'une équipe
idéale voyez les opérations
bladimir poutine a lancé une offensive
militaire contre l'ukraine le monde
retient son souffle alors que la russie
poursuit son offensive en ukraine
nous sommes à belgorod ce soir est à 50
km c'est crade qu'yves
[Musique]
formation
au you lose it chez rona karina
procureur
[Musique]
toros nash à cela nos clients
48 heures de couvre feu ça veut aussi
dire que les provisions à la maison sont
à sec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au dernier instant qu'ils ont
décidé de partir de tout laisser
derrière
[Musique]
les gens sortent manifester mais c'est
complètement interdit les gens vont
arrêter sous nos yeux
pourquoi
[Musique]
mardi
dur certaines c'est qu'après un mois
hier la russie ne menace pas la
population civile ici un complexe
d'appartements encore bien habité est
derrière moi un jardin d'enfants des
cibles militaires par contre autour on
n'envoie pas d'ici
jeudi on
l'imaginé extraite pour contrer
[Musique]
l'eau est à nouveau
oui
[Musique]
ailleurs des titulaires sont primés au
cort et 6 des situations
c
non
ochoa
[Musique]